let's go to David from Philadelphia
David from Philadelphia what's going on
today
I'm sorry
can you hear me yes I can
cool cool
first off I just want to say I listened
to that whole Dishon thing
um I disagree with everything he's
saying
he's full of it he's just like
live your life the way you want you know
if you identify as a woman it makes no
never mind to me if you identify as a
man makes no never mind to me
there so anyway I keep hearing you talk
about how conservatives and magas they
only subscribe to their principles when
it's convenient for them and drop it uh
once it's inconvenient correct right
well in with some with some principles
yes
I'd say all of them when it comes to uh
you know when it comes to capitalism
free market or with free speech or with
limited government like all of them you
know once uh it's inconvenient they drop
it okay yeah I mean with a lot of those
issues you're absolutely right yeah so
if we take that to its conclusion
would you say the only principle these
magas are consistent with is a white
supremacist
patriarchy where rich old white men are
on top and everybody else and everything
else is exploited exiled or eliminated
while the rich old white men just
consolidate and get as much power and
money as possible listen that's
absolutely the case for some parts of
the American right wing but not for all
of it and I don't think we gain anything
or Advance our cause by painting the
entire modern American right wing as a
white Supreme with a white supremacist
brush so I think you're correct that the
vast majority of the white supremacists
who want to put white Christian men at
the top of a hierarchy are voting more
for Republicans than Democrats that I
agree with but saying that that's what
the Republican party with the entire
right wing is at this point I don't
think it's productive nor is it
completely accurate it
okay I I appreciate that also let me
apologize for sounding a little
pretentious I've been doing a thousand
things at once and I'm just trying to
get all this out so it kind of sounds a
little I don't know combative
thank you I appreciate that I watch your
show all or listen to your show all the
time and uh you're one of the
better
um one of the better uh podcasters out
there you're very um very pragmatic you
believe in one thing but you understand
the reality of the situation and I
appreciate that and like not to knock
The Young Turks or uh Baron College
cousins but they're very uh you know why
isn't this the way it's supposed to be
and I appreciate that you understand why
stuff isn't the way it's supposed to be
even though you wish stuff would be the
way it would be that way all right David
from Philadelphia very much appreciate
the call let's take a very quick break
if you're holding on hold on because
we're going right back to the phones in
a moment